hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on four night and today we're
gonna be having some information about
from the recent data stream it's gonna
be stuff about the new open test some of
the new breach mode map gameplay from
the Viking in the samurai section and a
few other things like that so let's get
started with today's video
so first up as I said there's going to
be a open test for PC players only
available on Steam and you play from
September 6 all the way till September
10th preload will be available on the
4th or is no time yet but it's just so
that you can download it before it
actually starts you do not actually need
to own for honor to play this test so if
anybody that has a PC that doesn't have
the game you can actually play the open
test of marching fire on screen you'll
see what it comes with it's gonna be
coming with all the original heroes as
well as before woodland heroes making 22
playable heroes which is nice the
previous test only came with Shaolin and
T on D so now we hit James Jun and lucha
in the mix on top of that you could play
PvP PvE i and custom match with the new
pvp game mode breach in 44 and on all
three new masks which we'll get into in
a second but the old original one being
the walled city the Viking one being the
hallowed bastion and the kazan castle
being the samurai map also included in
the open test is custom match in Doolin
breach modes custom match on dedicated
servers the new perk system the
responsive dialogue system the UI update
graphical enhancements a victory
celebration screen which we haven't seen
yet and tons more so yeah like I said
this available to everyone on you play
PC and steam like all that type of stuff
so no Xbox no ps4 70 but if you do have
a PC even if you don't own the game you
can play this from September 6 to
September 10th so hopefully we can
livestream this I haven't got any
details yet from this but I will check
but if we can I'll gladly be streaming
it on those days just so we could show
off some of the gameplay like I said in
the beginning they also showed off some
of the new maps that's gonna be coming
in breech of course the original one
that everyone is seen in the breech
gameplay is the night map and it's gonna
be called walled city with the snowing
map being the Viking map called the
hallowed Bastion and the other map is
the samurai one called Kazan Castle I'll
be showing gameplay in the background
while I speak of this but the Viking map
seems to have a very similar style to
the night one and now everything is
designed over the lanes to attack our
from but the overall look and aesthetic
are obviously completely different the
unites one being a lot more hellish and
there's catapults everywhere and it's
just dark and gloomy to where the Viking
one is a lot more snowy and more bright
going off the Viking map like I said it
has this really cool snow texture to it
and but the gameplay elements are still
going to be the
in the same spot so it's only a
customization and look changes which is
nice like and there's also a huge giant
skull I believe on top of the four on
top of the fourth which I believe is
like a Viking mask or some ship either
way it looks really dope there so showed
the samurai map which looks like the one
temple from the campaign although it
could be wrong but this place seems to
have a lot more close quarters in small
alley ways to either ambush someone or
gain advantage point and as usual
there's a lot of zip lines to vault
throughout the map they really didn't
show much about these maps kind of just
showed what they look like and how they
designed it they also sadly didn't show
what the lords or the nut you know the
ending boss is gonna be only the Nights
one so hopefully we'll see that in the
test I'm assuming we're going to be so
if that's the case I cannot wait to see
what those big beefy guys look like
there's absolute units but yeah like I
said I'm gonna be having these gameplay
in the background just in case you guys
want to see more while I talk next is
gonna be patch 1.07 this can be coming
out on September 6 now I'm actually not
really gonna be showing you most of this
only because this is mostly just bug
fixes there's a few things on executions
you know stamina cost being reduced or
anything like that so just small bug
fixes for most of the cast well I just
wanted to let you guys know that this is
going to be coming out on September 6th
and what this patch has so if you do
want to see all of it though you can
look at the description down below I'll
leave a link to it you can look at all
the patch notes if you do want to read
that yourself next up is you're gonna be
seeing on screen is the new content of
the week and that's going to be elite
outfits the nights are gonna be getting
the outfit I believe called Sentinel or
Avalon the Vikings are gonna get phantom
Queen and the samurai blue that's
pronounced the key chi or de cachi
they're gonna be costing 7,000 stele
each let me know your thoughts and these
elite outfits in the comments below
love to know your thoughts I don't think
they're too bad but they are lean
outfits and I'd rather save my steel for
the characters and next bit of info is
that dual rank tournament is coming back
this weekend access the ranked lowest
front and located on your world map and
fight your way to the top of the
leaderboard this is gonna be coming from
August 31st to September 3rd so if you
are watching this on a Thursday it's
going to be tomorrow so basically next
weekend or this upcoming weekend I'm
gonna be gang able to play the dual
tournament ranked I probably to be doing
that on streams since I do like my
tournament ranking I'm not big on
regular dual ranked I like the
tournament a lot more just because the
easier Awards but either way hopefully
you guys do enjoy that and if you do
want to play some ranked play some
tournament and then also they released a
maintenance earlier today this is patch
1.2 6.4 and this had 4 bug fixes in it
and it fixed an issue that causes
Raiders Raider fury to improperly track
its target if Raider ended up switching
targets during the animation so that's
now fixed fixed an issue that caused
Boozer crews faint animation to be
missing that is now there as well fixed
an issue that caused Valkyries front row
to not led to the opponent and also
lastly fixed an issue that gladiator
Sucker Punch were not drained stamina
when performed from the left or right
stance and personally since I do play
like gladiator a lot I did experience
that last part a fair amount so I'm glad
that that is being fixed today is going
to be the end of the vid I hope you guys
did enjoy it look to me if you did
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational side of foreign or that
being valence changes here are updates
patch notes leaks and for the
information about foreign to keep
everyone up to date on what is coming in
the game and with that guys my two most
recent videos would be on screen if you
guys don't wanna check that out but that
guys are various today thanks for
watching the video and peace out
[Music]